welcome to this overview session on the
summer 2022 omix logic virtual training
programs the session will give you
additional details about the program
registration
levels of complexity and desired
outcomes you might be able to achieve
over the summer
we have a range of options that you can
look into further and register by the
end of may the programs
sorry the programs will be offered
virtually around the topics of coding in
r and python
infectious diseases and chronic diseases
as well as research project program that
will help you complete a full research
project leveraging public domain data
big data infrastructure training and
support from our mentors
so first of all let me introduce the
omixlogic program so the honors logic
programs are designed to provide
training and bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and beer at stanford
they help develop a growing community
with shared passion for data-driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
and they are designed to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data sciences
so
these methods are organized around
several topics such as oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
agriculture using a project-based
approach
and we
realized that a lot of people from a
life science background do not have the
dedication or maybe the time that it
takes
to really get trained in the technical
side of bioinformatics so we offer both
a code and no code bioinformatics paths
where you can learn about genomics
epigenomics metagenomics and other types
of omics data and apply them to
different types of research projects
leveraging our community of experts and
mentors and learning from online
tutorials
so before we begin the session and talk
in detail about the different programs
offered throughout the summer let's go
through the registration to the portal
and understand how this portal is going
to help anyone who's trying to maybe
brush up on their skills or learn a new
topic to really
make use of the online resources that we
have collected
so to start your journey you simply need
to sign up on learn
learn.omicslogic.com which is an
educational portal that will help you
get started in your bioinformatics
journey and also connect you to our
resources and support through a slack
channel
our community of professionals on
linkedin and our support team that can
communicate with you on social media
through slack or by email
so after you create an account which is
free
all you need to do is go to your account
by clicking on the top bar of the menu
and there you will find the ability to
update your profile name
make a
a picture add a picture like your
profile picture or maybe your university
logo
and start your tracking your activities
so that you can
see the different courses projects and
certificates that you obtain as you go
through the different exercises
ultimately these certificates are going
to validate what you know
but will also introduce you to a certain
level of skills that will allow you to
apply the bioinformatics skills that
you've gained to research projects
so let's talk a little bit about the
bloom's taxonomy of learning and how
this learning process actually happens
so the bloom taxonomy defines learning
as a series of steps from
knowing nothing about a domain to
becoming independent in that
skill or that knowledge
so it starts from understanding the
terminology maybe the specific details
and elements of a particular topic to
then understanding the concepts that are
more
difficult to grasp
then ability to apply skills like
algorithms techniques and methods to the
right kind of data
eventually becoming strategic so knowing
how to select the right method for the
right problem or the right question
and then the ability to create new
things so becoming knowledgeable enough
to be able to be creative
and so we will try to apply this
taxonomy or this learning process to
really
master certain skills and develop
independent and new projects using
bioinformatics
so what can you expect from completing
some of these programs over the summer
what you can expect is a
an opportunity uh kind of the potential
to be well versed in the terminology of
bioinformatics really understand what
different methods mean
how data is structured how is it
organized and how is it used by experts
in the field
and develop a personal profile where you
can showcase how much effort you've put
into
this kind of topic and how many skills
you've developed
ultimately leading to an independent
project that you can also post on your
profile
and link all of that information
together and i will talk in much greater
detail about how this is organized on
the portal and how these programs can
actually help you get there
but before we get there i will briefly
mention that the program
this summer is going to be sponsored by
the louisiana bioinformatics research
network which is a network of
universities in louisiana across the
state of louisiana
and
includes sorry
uh louisiana state university louisiana
tech
southern university southeastern
louisiana university xavier and others
and
it really is a one of the example
of programs that are also now starting
this year are welcome to participate in
these online training programs and
these idea programs are scattered
throughout the united states
participants in puerto rico for example
pr inbree
in louisiana as i mentioned
in west virginia and others and so what
we do is we actually
bring together experts from all of these
different parts of the country to
support the training and offer
mentorship and we started offering these
programs just this year and we're
excited to share that we had a number of
participants that have already completed
a number of programs
from january up until march that
included an introduction to
bioinformatics genomic data analysis
metagenomic data analysis and data
science for biomedical data and we were
excited to see that many of them were
able to gain
points or kind of experiences
that they could then hopefully apply to
their research projects and to
different types of topics that they are
interested in
and here's just an example of several
participants that have completed just
this past cohort
including people from university of
hawaii
university of nebraska medical center
and many other locations throughout the
network
so this was
just to illustrate that this is
available throughout the national
association of idea principal
investigators which is a network that
links together 23 states and puerto rico
under this program funded by nih called
the idea program
so what can you find on the onyx logic
portal to get started you will see that
you will have an access to a searchable
database of courses and projects
they are organized by tags for example
you can learn
how to perform the analysis in r and
python or you might want to learn about
a specific type of data like genomics
metagenomics or others and you will also
find collections down here at the bottom
and one of the collections if you're
completely new to bioinformatics is a
collection called getting started so if
you click there you will find kind of
the basic things they need to know to
get started with bioinformatics
after you start enrolling into some of
these you will see that each activity
will come with a certain number of
points for example for completing a
course you will earn 500 points for
running a pipeline 100 points for
updating your profile 100 points or for
group activity 10 points so these
elements of activity will actually help
you go from a beginner to intermediate
to an advanced level and those levels
are going to showcase
what you are going to be able to do with
all of these skills
each course comes with a certificate
each project comes with a certificate
and the programs come with a certificate
as well and these certificates are going
to be signed by the experts either in
the louisiana biomedical research
network or throughout nappy by the
president of nepi
so that you can actually bring this to
your university or to your api and
showcase what you have learned
now importantly these
courses prepare you to apply the
bioinformatics skills to projects and so
we have this case study approach
the case study approach has been
popularized
in business schools
in law schools in medicine and really
what it tries to achieve is to give you
a glimpse of how these methods that you
typically learn about in a textbook are
applied to specific problems and so here
we will take a number of different
examples based on your interest so when
you think about these programs you will
see that they are focused around these
areas of application and so based on
your ideas about where you want to apply
bioinformatics and for data science you
should be able to select the right kind
of program for you
so in
2022
uh this summer
we're going to be offering these four
programs
plus everyone can have this access to
getting started with bioinformatics
now there's going to be limited seats
available for free if you would like to
join for free you can but you will have
to go through the right channels and so
if you're coming from louisiana you will
have to interact with lsu biomed
which is the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine at
the louisiana state university
there this lab is going to be able to
approve a scholarship for you to
complete the program
and you can only participate in that
particular program if you are a part of
any of these louisiana based
universities undergraduate primarily
undergraduate universities puis
and you would have to identify the right
person
in there to
ask about this opportunity and get
funded through
lbrn
now to do so you will receive an email
if you're from louisiana if you've
registered as a person from louisiana
you will receive an email with the link
of how to get registered
now for other people who are
a part of nepi
there's an additional pool of licenses
available through the national
association of idea principal
investigators and there
excuse me
there you also have to just come from a
university or a lab or a core that is a
member of nepe
so being a member of nepy means that
your pi the national idea the national
association of idea principal
investigators means that your pi
is funded and pays the membership dues
in nepe so if you don't know if you are
and you would like us to help you figure
that out you can contact me or our team
and if you filled out the form you
should be receiving some emails about
that registration process
now if you want to know today uh you can
just put your university name or lab
name or pi name in the chat box and i
can then check about that uh the
membership of those
pis
so how will these programs be organized
and structured
the way that they're organized is that
we have interactive zoom sessions kind
of like today where we go through a
specific topic we practice some
coding exercise or maybe building a
pipeline or looking at the results and
trying to interpret them
we will also have discussions and those
discussions can be either in the live
session
or offline on slack by email by chat uh
and what we are trying to find is are
some good times where the majority of
the people can actually join a live
session but if you don't have the same
time available you're busy and you want
to do this at your own pace that is
probably going to be
the best scenario for you as well
because the program will also leverage
extensive online self-guided study
materials that are embedded into these
live sessions so really the best time to
come to the live session is after you've
completed those assignments you have
tried those exercises you understand
what your questions are and that makes
those sessions really productive
so what are the types of things that
we're going to cover in each one of
these programs that's kind of the
general overview of how they will be
organized but let's look at the specific
details of each program
so
as i mentioned for everyone and this is
by the way a free course so you're
welcome to start that at any point in
time we offer a basic package of how to
get started with bioinformatics and uh
that is essential for especially those
that don't have any background in
bioinformatics statistics or coding so
if you're absolutely new i recommend
just signing up on the portal
learn.omixlogic.com
and that will be
covered by
any of these organizations
and will be available for
if you're a part of a university or
student or a faculty at a university and
that will come with a certificate
but to really benefit from all of the
resources of the program
you will then have to kind of choose
which program you would like to
participate in and so let me talk
briefly what is what are some additional
resources that we have for each one of
these programs
so each one of these programs includes
specifically design training materials
data analysis tools curated project data
sets and these interactive sessions that
cover a certain range of topics and so
as you think about the specific goals
that you would like to achieve during
the summer think
is it mastering a specific skill
for example starting to code in python
and r could be a skill that you can gain
over the summer
is it applying
some of these
tools to a particular type of a project
or maybe a project that is related to
the type of research that you're doing
or planning to do
and
specifically if you are trying to
um you know apply this to an independent
research project you will be able to
utilize some of the big data analysis
tools because typically that's one of
the limitations you don't have enough
resources to really process analyze and
interpret the data that you have
now beyond that we will also have guest
lecturers that are going to be speaking
about all of these specific areas of
bioinformatics applications
that have a background in genomics in
sequencing in bioinformatics and in
biomedical data science
overall you will have access to a lot of
computational resources so the
computational resources that we will
provide are included with the tbi and
for platform and that offers five
terabytes of storage
cloud containers that you can deploy and
also a lot of technical support to help
you navigate the different pipelines
select the right ones and make sure that
you can run them successfully
what do these pipelines look like
the pipelines are combining
interactive learning
that is important for bioinformatics
with the actual tools that make that
that apply those methods to a specific
research problem and so you will be able
to select between many different
pipelines
learn about the different options and
then produce interactive results that
you can explore
to really understand a particular topic
now overall the program will follow this
kind of a progression from speaking
about the context for example some
project idea
or an experiment that somebody did to
them the logic why and how to combine
and use and select different types of
tools to analyze such data
practice those tools and eventually
become independent by understanding what
goes in technically into making those
analysis methods work
so eventually you will actually end up
having
several different resources like
pipelines and code
that you can take with you and reuse and
apply to different types of research
challenges that you might face
so the first program that i want to talk
about briefly is a
an introductory course on biomedical
data analysis using r and python so in
this course you will go from the
platform where you will kind of
understand the different applications of
these coding methods
to then
exercises in both r and python
from the very beginner things like
learning how to load sequences and
compare sequences to each other to
advance things like applying machine
learning and deep learning to complex
data sets in cancer
metabolic diseases neuroscience and
others
so what you will find is that we have
designed a coding playground where you
will be able to actually follow
exercises and get the right kinds of
results
in these primary languages that are
being used not only in bioinformatics
but in fact in data science in general
here in 2019
a
survey
for job applications has found that
python and r are in top demand and one
of the reasons for that is that they
also bring a huge community of
researchers that utilize these methods
and develop packages that are now
commonly used in different areas of
research
and are
extremely
easy to use today compared to kind of
writing everything from scratch so that
will really be the focus of this program
so um these are going to be online
exercises that you can complete
again some advanced topics will be
highlighted in the sessions that we will
have
but you will see that you know these are
going to be starting from very simple
and basic things to more and more
advanced things and you will go through
the following kind of topics
uh data wrangling right how to handle
raw data how to prepare for analysis
machine learning and statistics how to
understand conceptually what these
methods do and why we have them
then an in-depth review of unsupervised
and supervised machine learning
including machine learning for data
visualization
different types of methods like
clustering and classification feature
selection and significant pattern
recognition and then regression and
generalized linear models as well as
deep learning types and applications so
you will really find a lot of these
topics covered in these online
as well as the live sessions
as i mentioned you will go from very
basic
to more and more advanced
exercises and those exercises eventually
will lead you to become independent by
learning how to set up an online
technical environment and share your
interactive notebooks with others so
that your analysis could be reproducible
and shareable with others
now a big part of this training will
include
the understanding of the link between
the data that you're analyzing and the
biology that it represents we'll
ask difficult questions about why
certain methods are being used how are
they used to make biological conclusions
and why is it important to understand
the methodology and kind of the
statistical aspects of these methods to
be able to rely on them in answering
complex biological questions
we will also
understand the tools that we have to be
able to compare and contrast different
methods and make conclusions about how
to design a deployable workflow
for somebody to use in the real-life
setting
and it's important that i think in the
biostatistics and this research type
application of biostatistics and machine
learning
there is really a complex process that
combines the biological understanding
the experimental design the application
of the analysis and many other areas to
design a workflow that really
can be effective and reproducible and i
think what's important is that you will
have the opportunity to understand how
these methods are used
in diagnostics and cancer biology in
single cell analysis in microbial
infection and maybe many others
many other research areas and projects
second program that we will have is a
program designed around transcriptomic
data
transcriptomic data today can be viewed
as single cell and bulk rna seq analysis
and both are equally important so a lot
of the understanding of gene expression
today is based on bulk rna-seq data and
more and more people are starting to get
involved in single cell rnaced studies
and so we will try to cover both of
these approaches in some detail
now the major idea behind
transcriptomics is that when we want to
study translation or proteins that are
being produced we can actually use the
transcriptome as a proxy and we can take
everything that is being transcribed by
the ribosome
to really understand what are some of
those products that are being produced
inside the cell and to study that we can
use
different methods of rna quantification
including
western blot
microarray studies and others and today
the majority of these studies are being
performed using what's called next
generation or second generation
sequencing techniques called high
throughput techniques and they allow us
to
generate large
volumes of big data that later on can be
used to study interactions between the
biological mechanism and the phenotype
as well as define some of those broad
clinical categories and potentially even
identify treatments and therapeutic
interventions into these complex
processes
so the onyx logic transfer comics
program will cover these important
aspects of rna-seq
providing you with an overview of tools
and resources for transcriptomic data
analysis
so that you know how to prepare and
process next generation sequencing data
for downstream analysis
comparative analysis such as
differential gene expression exploratory
and machine learning analyses as well
and importantly we'll also focus on
analysis of single cell rna-seq data
where you will be able to understand the
commonly used packages and try to
practice them on your own
so the process will include
understanding specific pipelines where
the logic of analysis will be clearly
delineated with colors and
interactive outputs that you can
connect to the biological phenomena that
is being studied
but also will provide you an in-depth
view of what the data actually looks
like and why it is so important to
understand the data and the methods to
be able to spot unwanted variation and
ultimately
prepare your data for these more
advanced methods of analysis that allow
you to find non-linear relationships and
data and really answer complex questions
now with the advance of transcriptomics
into single cell transcriptomics we are
seeing many uh uh kind of exciting new
methods and approaches being developed
to study the transcription at
unprecedented
level of detail and that includes
methods to differentiate between
different types of cells for example
immune cells brain cells different
tissue cells and really understand
variation of gene expression at that
tissue
or cell type level
and importantly today we have methods
that allow us to
understand how they can help us
differ understand the differentiation
and and ultimately find important trends
in that data
to understand these complex processes
and map them
visually so that we can study them
better
to
understand how these methods are used we
will use several different project
examples and i'll just give you a
glimpse of a few of them but then in the
program itself we will cover several
additional ones as well
those include
patient-derived
xenograph models
different types of
analysis
of different types of
genomic and transcriptomic data
and a lot of them are going to be
specifically around cancer and
chronic diseases
now in addition to that type of
application of transcriptomic data we
also offer another program called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and this is going to be a little bit
different because here we're going to be
focused on methods specifically used to
study infection with different types of
pathogens
so let me briefly switch gears and talk
a little bit about the difference
between chronic and infectious diseases
and that will give you a good sense of
how these programs are actually
different so infectious diseases are
spread directly or indirectly and
specifically they're caused by pathogens
whereas chronic diseases are not caused
by pathogen typically even though we'll
see that there is some overlap and
they're caused by environment
nutritional deficiencies lifestyle
choices and genetic inheritance so a
good example of an infectious disease
is when a bacteria because of its
ability to replicate uncontrollably ends
up colonizing an organ or a tissue
causing that organ or tissue to not
function properly
ultimately they also produce
different types of
you know substances that cause
stress and ultimately release of toxins
and that can lead to organ function
interference and damage now importantly
we've seen the applications of
bioinformatics in recent outbreaks such
as the outbreak that we're experiencing
right now
and we need to understand kind of the
history of how genomics has been used to
help us address these kinds of outbreaks
in a very comprehensive manner including
the ability to
uh understand the viral pathology so how
a virus for example causes pathogenesis
or the development of the disease
helps us develop diagnostic tools so we
can differentiate between different
strains of pathogens for example
including understanding of antibiotic
resistance
resistance to different types of drugs
etc
also helps us really predict how a
specific strain might continue to evolve
and anticipate that so that we can be
more prepared both from a public health
and from a diagnostic and infectious
disease perspectives
now the uh
the pandemic that we're in right now i
think really highlighted how different
types of omics data need to be
integrated to be able to study and
understand what's really going on and we
saw this
when we
kind of observed the current pandemic
the different strains that emerged the
way that those strains affected the
spike protein right so today a lot of
these
terms are being commonly used but what
we'll do in this specific program is
we'll look at how
genomic data has been utilized to study
understand and even design interventions
for outbreaks of such infectious
diseases
and to do that we'll look at analysis
methods for sequence variation
phylogenetic analyses uh functional
inference by looking at
protein structures and host response in
terms of transcriptomic
analysis so this program will include a
lot of
hands-on exercises
curated data sets from different
outbreaks like source code 2 ebola virus
malaria and others and we'll provide an
environment where you can analyze such
data and start asking important
questions about these
infectious diseases and their outbreaks
now finally i want to talk about the
last program called the bioinformatics
research fellowship so the research
fellowship is really designed for those
that want to complete a research project
throughout the summer
and by completing a research project you
can kind of address those two
issues training
and working independently with the right
resources mentorship and guidance that
this program provides
ultimately the goal of this program is
to develop a project think of it as a
presentation at a poster presentation
maybe
or a starting point for your
bioinformatics analysis paper
the important
structure of this program helps you
address those critical stages that
prevent many people from publishing or
completing their analysis in a
meaningful way
and the first one of those starts with
choosing the right kind of a topic so
we'll talk a lot about how to perform
literature review
how to make sure that you can pick the
right topic and how to make sure that
you can plan your analysis so that you
can complete it in a certain time frame
in a predictable time frame and then
obviously to address the technical
challenges along the way we will provide
you with the support and the
infrastructure to make sure that you
have everything you need to finish that
project
now the first part of that includes
this
comprehensive curriculum that provides
examples of how others have used
different types of methods of analysis
to address these complex questions and
you'll be able to
read through that literature and
understand how people have selected the
focus of their analysis performed
different stages of analysis and then
presented their analysis results in such
a way that it is compelling uh visually
attractive
clear and importantly that it is novel
and and aligned with your research
interest and so that's where we will
focus on your project
we'll go through
a series of exercises to
identify gaps in current research and
select a meaningful topic and then you
will be introduced to the environment
where mentors can guide you on refining
that question and really turning that
into a research study
the program is organized around weekly
progress reports where you will be able
to share with your mentor a report about
your
you know focus
the progress with the coursework your
practice get some evaluation and
feedback
and also be able to interact with both
the others in the program and the
mentors to get guidance in a timely
fashion
now during this program you'll be able
to focus on any one of these areas
including precision medicine population
health biotechnology and agriculture and
space and astrobiology and you will be
provided with an interface where you can
complete your profile achieve the
necessary results with the training by
completing several courses that we
recommend
and eventually being able to submit a
full project that you can then present
and so here are some examples of people
that have gone through that process
delara for example has completed the
training and then submitted her project
on bioarchive one of the outcomes
you can see here semai delano was able
to publish her research in an
undergraduate journal but we also had
other members that have actually
utilized their skills to advance their
ongoing research projects such as
olga from roswell park comprehensive
cancer center
foul from louisiana state university and
many others and what's exciting about
this is that at the end of this process
we will be organizing another omics
research symposium which is scheduled
for august so anyone that registers for
these online programs completes them
will be able to participate in the
poster session where we have experts
from both industry and academia
speaking about cutting-edge topics in
bioinformatics research and training but
also providing feedback to those
students that have completed their
projects and would like to take them
further would like to advance their
skills apply them to important
challenges and topics and also be able
to present their research findings to
the global community
around those research domains
so with that we're going to
wrap up this particular presentation
again what did we cover today we spoke
about the different summer research and
training programs that are going to be
offered uh in the summer of 2022
the registration deadline is going to be
by the end of may with some exceptions
available throughout the first couple of
weeks of june
but once you decide on the program you
can
have two choices you can join the basic
training but also one of the advanced
programs
unless you are focused on the research
fellowship where you are going to be
working for
the whole summer to complete an
independent research project and then be
able to present it here at the onyx
research symposium
in the end of august
so if you have any additional questions
i am
going to be available uh on this email
ilia
pine.bio eli a pine dot pyle but you can
also communicate with our team at
marketing at omixlogic.com
as well as marketing
marketing
at pine.bio
so if you have any questions about the
registration uh the um right kind of
institution to go through if you're
interested in
getting um through nepi the national
association of idea principal
investigators or the louisiana
biomedical research network
we will be able to guide you to the
right contact person and they will be
able to
explain the technical details of this
process
now we will have this webinar again so i
welcome you to stay in touch make sure
that you uh put the mail in your mailbox
and you can find all the links there
and if you have any questions again feel
free to reach out to me
so thank you again for joining today i
hope to see you throughout the programs
and
i hope you have a good rest of your day
thank you